[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta en esta ocasión vamos a
el lugar donde ocurrió el primer
atentado terrorista en Costa de Marfil
el 13 de marzo de 2016 tres atacantes
armados con kalashnikovs abrieron Fuego
en la playa y luego en los hoteles de la
costa 45 minutos de horror antes de que
fueran abatidos por las fuerzas
especiales marfileñas el número de
víctimas mortales del atentado ascendió
a 19 9 de ellas extranjeras y más de 30
heridos el ataque fue reivindicado por
al qaeda del magreb islámico unos meses
antes Costa de Marfil había detenido a
yihadistas de esta organización
terrorista y los había entregado a Mali
el país también estaba pagando por su
cooperación con Francia en las
operaciones anti yihadistas en el sael
el pasado diciembre casi 7 años después
de los hechos
cuatro hombres fueron condenados a
cadena perpetua por el tribunal penal de
abellán se les acusó de ayudar a los
terroristas y los acusados apelaron la
decisión por otro lado los presuntos
autores intelectuales del atentado
Fueron condenados por Rebeldía algunos
de ellos están prófugos y otros
detenidos en Mali sin embargo este
juicio no esclareció los hechos más allá
de los sobrevivientes y las familias de
las víctimas toda una región todo un
país sigue conmocionado por este
atentado Esta es la historia
la playa de Gran bazam situada a unos 40
kilómetros de la capital económica de
Costa de Marfil se ha convertido en el
símbolo de una tragedia
edira Ross trabaja duro para que gran
asamble nazca
sin embargo fue aquí hace siete años
donde estuvo a punto de perder la vida
bajo los disparos de tres terroristas
limpiar la playa es una forma de terapia
para ella y otros sobrevivientes
empezamos la ong después del atentado
del 13 de marzo de 2016 porque había
mucha
basuradistas pasaron por acá pero no
podemos dejar que gran bazam se
convierta en un basurero
eso fue lo que nos motivó entonces
Veníamos a recoger residuos plásticos a
la playa y al mismo tiempo hablábamos
Por qué pasaste tú qué viste Así que
también era sanador el día de la
tragedia evirá estaba en Primera fila
fue testigo de los primeros disparos de
los terroristas allá fue donde
dispararon allá fue donde cayó porque yo
estaba sentada acá ahí fue donde cayó
nunca olvidaré este lugar había sangre
por todas partes era una masacre la
gente gritaba por todas partes corría
por todas partes
evirá junto con su hijo y los hijos de
su vecino tuvo que arrastrarse por la
arena para escapar de las balas
Ese fue un domingo negro para mí
ver morir a alguien
alguien murió frente a mí por primera
vez eso es algo que uno ve en televisión
decía que era una pesadilla
que alguien me iba a pellizcar para
despertarme
para decirme que ya había pasado pero
era la realidad
ver morir a alguien frente a mí
recordaré toda mi vida
ese hombre que cayó y su mujer
muchas veces cuando camino por ese
pasillo todavía los veo
cuando dicen 13 de marzo los veo
se llamaba foto tenía 28 años Fue la
primera víctima
a él le siguieron otros 18 y alrededor
de 30 heridos graves
pasaron 45 minutos hasta la llegada de
las fuerzas especiales madrileñas
[Música]
el grupo de al qaeda del magreb islámico
reivindicó rápidamente el atentado
los bomberos civiles de Gran bazam
fueron de los primeros en llegar al
lugar para socorrer a las víctimas
[Música]
era el jefe de la brigada en aquel
entonces
cuando llegamos allá todo el mundo está
oyendo la firmemente
los cadáveres estaban por todas partes
parecía que hubiéramos llegado después
de una guerra
no teníamos vehículos de intervención o
sea ambulancias así que tuvimos que
utilizar nuestros propios vehículos que
no estaban hechos para esa intervención
si hubiéramos tenido otras condiciones
Por ejemplo si el cuartel hubiera estado
más cerca del centro de la ciudad Se
habría reducido el tiempo de
intervención y habríamos podido
intervenir rápidamente y tal vez salvar
a esas personas
en 2017 un año después del Atentado La
jefe Bamba asumió la jefatura del
cuartil desde su llegada traslado el
centro de mando al centro de la ciudad a
unos cientos de metros de la playa
lo dotó de dos ambulancias y un camión
cisterna reabasteció el centro con
material de primeros auxilios y organizó
entrenamientos específicos
por favor asegúrense de seguir las
reglas la aplicación al principio de su
turno hagan el inventario al final de su
turno hagan el inventario
[Música]
hubo un accidente
ahora tenemos más medios estamos muy
bien equipados en recursos humanos y
logísticos
[Música]
como ya fuimos Víctimas de un atentado
no nos rendimos
desde entonces nos concentramos mucho en
la prevención
sí la previsión en la prevención para
que no nos tomen por sorpresa
cada 13 de marzo a las 12:30 del día se
organiza una marcha en conmemoración de
la masacre los bomberos participan todos
los años
[Música]
también es una oportunidad para que los
políticos locales se acerquen a la
población
[Música]
procederemos a la colocación de la
corona de flores en nombre del gobierno
y sin más preámbulos guardaremos Un
minuto de silencio
[Música]
los nombres de las 19 víctimas están
grabados en piedra
la mayoría marfileños pero también una
macedonia una alemana un libanés un
nigeriano y cuatro franceses
para el alcalde de Gran bazam este modo
de vida internacional también estaba en
la mira gran bazam es un símbolo es la
capital de las artes y la cultura una
ciudad cosmopolita abierta al mundo
desde la época colonial
y creo que son estos símbolos esta
apertura esta forma de vida y de
convivencia lo que los autores de este
atentado querían atacar
el mayor impacto se sintió en los meses
posteriores al atentado de Gran bazam en
términos del descenso del número de
visitantes a la ciudad de Gran bazam que
es el principal destino turístico de
Costa de Marfil para reactivar la
industria turística que es la principal
fuente de ingresos de Gran bazam el
estado proporcionó una ayuda de 300
millones de francos ffa el equivalente a
450.000 euros electoral hotel
emblemático de Gran bazam fue uno de los
hoteles afectados por el atentado
recibió esta ayuda pero para su gerente
Luis Marta esta suma es insuficiente los
ingresos del Hotel han caído un 80%
hoy ni siquiera tenemos habitaciones
ocupadas estoy en contacto directo con
los clientes tienen miedo de venir
tienen miedo de ser agredidos
estamos a punto de cerrar nuestras
puertas
no tenemos el dinero para una renovación
Porque también se trata de eso
tenemos que renovar nuestra imagen pero
hay que tener los medios para hacerlo
recuperar la imagen de Gran bazam
también significa garantizar la
seguridad en todo el territorio
marfileño en 2017 se lanzó un proyecto
sin precedentes La Academia
internacional de lucha contra el
terrorismo
este centro de formación que se extiende
a lo largo de 1.200 hectáreas recibe
cada año cerca de 600 alumnos
procedentes de toda África
nada
esta semana viajaron alumnos desde
senegal togo
cada quien trabaja a su manera con su
propia lógica por lo que teníamos que
llegar a un consenso lo hablamos mucho y
la repartición de las tareas fue muy
interesante
[Aplausos]
después de las clases los alumnos ponen
la teoría en práctica
el escenario es que hubo un atentado
esta mañana
con cuatro terroristas
unas cinco o seis víctimas y los
terroristas se dieron a la fuga
Aunque llueve a cántaros el
entrenamiento continúa todo recuerdan el
ataque de Gran basada
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los escenarios y modos operando y de
esta simulaciones cambian constantemente
ocurrió el primer atentado terrorista
pero desde entonces Costa de Marfil ha
sufrido otros el más sangriento fue el
decafolo en la frontera con burkina faso
en 2020 allí perdieron la vida 14
soldados marfileños
la sina viaja es experto en terrorismo
en la región del sael estudia la
evolución de La amenaza y las
estrategias para contenerla
Dale en el contexto de 2016 eran
atentados hoy han evolucionado hacia una
nueva dimensión que podría llamarse
conquista territorial
es necesario adoptar una postura
preventiva más que una postura
reaccionaria Es cierto que van de la
mano pero hay que hacer hincapié en la
prevención que es lo que consta de
Marfil intenta hacer hoy de ahí a la
creación de un instituto de
investigación estratégico en el seno de
la academia la lucha contra el
terrorismo también se Libra en el plano
judicial
Luis como las demás víctimas y
sobrevivientes tuvo que esperar siete
años para que se hiciera justicia
junto con otras ocho personas presentó
una demanda civil
de los 10 acusados solo cuatro
estuvieron en el juicio considerados los
ayudantes del atentado
se les acusó de haber ayudado a los
atacantes con el transporte el
alojamiento y la planeación
los otros seis fueron juzgados en
Rebeldía todos fueron condenados a
cadena perpetua su abogado apeló El
veredicto
[Música]
ellos mismos declararon no tener
relación alguna con estos hechos
no tienen ningún vínculo con estos
delitos desde fracción Así que son
inocentes y desarrollamos nuestro
alegato basándonos en eso
Luis asistió a todas las audiencias se
sumergió en el doloroso relato del
atentado en cada una de estas
revivirlo todo es una victoria una
victoria porque Vimos a los culpables
una victoria porque hay seguridad
pero también somos infelices en el mundo
gente que iba a hablar con ellos y
preguntarles Por qué que me respondan
por qué lo hicieron por qué nos dejaron
a todos sumidos en el caos con los
presuntos autores intelectuales aún en
libertad este veredicto les deja un
sabor amargo a los Testigos y
sobrevivientes es difícil saber si la
mayoría de los habitantes de Gran bazam
se sienten realmente seguros pero Todos
quieren seguir con sus vidas se celebran
las fiestas tradicionales y el número de
fuerzas del orden es duplicado la
prefecta nasus insiste en una estrategia
participativa el día 13 aquí había gente
que parecía sospechosa si hubiéramos
estado atentos habríamos visto sus
movimientos habríamos evitado cosas lo
que quiero decir es que confíen en
nosotros si ven algo raro vayan a las
autoridades incluso pueden ir a la
alcaldía
siete años después de los atentados los
habitantes de Gran bazam celebran la paz
y la cohesión social está la juventud
todos están acá significa que gran bazam
revivió y eso me alegra
[Música]
gambas hambre vivió solo espera el
regreso de los turistas
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta desde Costa de
Marfil visitamos
el primer ataque terrorista que vivió el
país y vimos el impacto social y
económico que generó este atentado en
toda la población
recuerde que puede Ingresar a nuestra
página web France 24.com para ver esta
emisión y las anteriores hasta la
próxima